Oh fellas looks as though we have
company what the hell are you niggers
doing here we are the TAM heels we
traveled all the way back to the town to
call your cracker watch your mouth
actually you better watch your mouth
white boy before I put these Gators up
your ass and show you inside some staff
[Music]
he's gonna pull that a whip nice whip
this here is a pistol reach for the sky
honking oh okay honk is a racial epithet
used for white people was made popular
by a man named George Jefferson in the
nineteen seventies you see he and his
wife Weezy had a dry-cleaning business
so they would own up to these sent to a
deal outs apartment in the sky they
finally got a piece of the path
Tom who the story I'll admit but the
point is this that in the future Oh
black people will be free and in saying
that I this is what stopped the whole
Sheldon stop I mean literally the whole
episode came to a screeching halt right
here's a matter of fact I can predict
this episode come to a screeching halt
right now but I'll show it when's we
won't be free that is a good question my
man how about now is apparently shooting
a slave man's there isn't plenty -
anybody would be illegal
if I could I'd do it every episode